this is the 360 fly one of a new crop of
virtual reality cameras and camera rigs
which sets it apart from other systems
is that it's relatively treat and has
just one lens lens with an astonishing
250 degree field of view it's also
waterproof down to 165 feet I wanted to
give this camera a fair chance at
blowing us away so we teamed up with the
California Academy of Sciences to get a
virtual look inside their stunning
Steinhart aquarium there's a lot of
small details about this camera that I
really appreciate the design of school
the construction is solid and two
incredibly simple to use there are no
awkward LCD displays no confusing menus
just a simple on/off button and a mobile
app that's as easy to use as the camera
itself when paired with the ability to
seamlessly be your footage and virtual
reality using google cardboard it puts
VR content creation in the hands of your
average consumer you'd also embed your
clips online and give viewers the
ability to scroll through your film full
360-degree to build of you if you're
really into VR the 360 fly might be a
great way to experiment but it's not for
everyone even though the resolution is
considered high definition it's not
comparable to say an iphone success or
nexus 6 in other words you won't be
getting those clients perfection shots
that you've been dreaming about the
first generation products showing great
promise with the narrow field of view
and overall image quality still leave a
lot to be desired at least for the time
being creating virtual reality content
of any quality is still out of reach for
most of us for now save that four
hundred dollars and take a trip to the
cal academy or aquarium or get some
scuba lessons turns out actual reality
still the best experience around
you